[Music]
hannah in tacoma washington who happens
to be joining us right now on the show
hannah how are you doing
i'm good how are you great how can john
and i help today
um i was just calling me and my partner
just got engaged and he actually just
told me about the baby steps maybe three
weeks ago congratulations and welcome to
the game
so i have my thousand dollar starter
fund and
i've paid off two credit cards in the
last three weeks way to go
way to go
thank you the reason for my call is i
know you guys say don't combine your
finances until you're actually married
correct which is completely
understandable
but i was wondering since i'm the one
with debt and he's set free
would it be
kind of skipping steps if i had him save
up our three to six months emergency
fund because we do live together
um we just don't have like joint
accounts or anything and then i continue
to pay off my debt by myself
while he
does our three to six month emergency
fund is that
when are you guys getting married
um
well we're going through pre-marital
counseling right now and we haven't
picked a for sure date but we were
thinking about doing like a courthouse
elopement now and then have a real
wedding later when
there's a little less covid and a little
more savings
let's let's go over a little more like a
country song a little less covet a
little more savings i like it
so here's the thing you were right that
you guys should not combine finances and
here's the thing you are on your own
journey right now in the baby steps
paying off your debt he's on his own
journey debt-free building up his
emergency fund and so this is not a our
situation yet and so if if i'm him i'm
just saving up my emergency fund and
when it comes time for us to get married
well guess what we are now in baby step
2 paying off our debt
right are y'all how do y'all split the
bills up right now
um we do
uh the susie i can't remember her last
name it's like this mathematical
equation where you figure out your
percentages susie orman's pythagorean
theorem
so
yeah something like that is ours not
good enough for you no
how do you how do you determine who pays
what bill
oh well we add all of the bills that are
our bills so like internet rent for the
apartment we both live in and stuff like
that we just add that up and then we
find out the percentage based on who
makes what amount of money oh wow so
it's skewed if you if he makes more
money he has a bigger share of the bills
correct interesting even if that was his
idea even if you like just leave the
lights on all over the house see how
this gets messy real fast
yeah where this makes way more sense and
we get pushback from all over the place
makes
way more financial sense
marital sense
and it makes way more partnership sense
like you and i are in this together
because we got married is to put all of
your accounts when you get married put
all your account put all of your money
into the same account
and everything comes out of there when
you start dividing up responsibilities
by who makes more and who doesn't last
and all that is a marital recipe for a
relationship implosion because you're
always going to be saying well i did
dinner well then you should you know we
always have that one for him this is
before venmo of course we always had
that one friend that would be like hey
uh you owe me 4.28 cents i got wendy's
like four years ago and you're like what
do you talk that's what our marriages
turn into when we live like that i love
your idea of
running to the courthouse and getting
married and starting from scratch here
and just saying all right we're all
putting all of our money together every
month we're combining it there will be
seasons when you make more he makes more
whatever it is and then we're going to
build that out of that together right i
love that place right how much debt do
you have left uh i have it i got it down
from 37 000 to i think it's like 36
and some change okay um right now and
i make 35 000 a year right now but i am
lucky to have gotten a job right before
the pandemic where we have a union
negotiated 50 cent raise every six
months
um
so it's steadily climbing up every six
months and then i am in line right now
to actually
change positions
sometime maybe the next six months which
would change my pay grade on the scale
very cool okay awesome well good luck
hannah congrats on the engagement but
hey stick to the journey on your own
until you guys are married and things
will be better for it yeah so right now
just to refresh until you all get
married you need to have your emergency
fund he's got to have his emergency fund
and right now you are dumping everything
on cash
and he's going to take an emergency fund
out of his whatever magical percentage
you'll have come up with and they uh
yeah the new the new you've never heard
of that mathematical formula
that's just like that would cause a lot
of resentment i can't even tell you i
just feels like such a disaster